c'est l'histoire d'une bonne nouvelle
finalement pas si bonne que cela sur la
première notice d'utilisation de son
vaccin anti qu'ovide fighter bio ntech
indique qu'un flacon contient cinq doses
de vaccin est qu'il permet donc de
vacciner cinq personnes
pour bien comprendre il faut savoir que
le vaccin files heures nécessite une
petite préparation avant de pouvoir être
injectés à un flacon de vaccins le
soignant doit ajouter 1,8 mille litres
de chlorure de sodium ce qui donne 2,25
millilitres de produits injectables par
flacon la dose qui doit être administré
à chaque patient étant de 0,3 mille
litres de produit un flacon doit en
principe permettre de vacciner au moins
six personnes
rapidement les équipes vaccinales s'en
rendent compte et relayent l'information
l'agencé européenne du médicament leem s
y intéressent à son tour et décide de
valider l'utilisation de cette 6ème dose
ondes aux bonus mais avec un protocole
assez stricte le comité des médicaments
à usage humain chmp de limeil recommande
de mettre à jour les informations sur le
produit comme lire nati pour préciser
que chaque flacon contient 6 doses du
vaccin pour extraire sidos d'un seul
flacons et des seringues et ou des
aiguilles dit à faible espace morts
doivent être utilisé l'espace mort de la
combinaison seringues et aiguilles à
faible espace mort ne doit pas dépasser
les 35 microlitre si des seringues et
des aiguilles standards sont utilisés il
se peut qu'il n'y ait pas assez de
produits pour extraire une sixième dose
d'un flacon
mais dans la pratique et compte tenu de
ce protocole
il est parfois difficile pour le
personnel soignant de prélever du flacon
la fameuse sixième doses d'autant que
tous n'ont pas accès aux fameuses
seringue préconisée par l' agence pour
l'instant les médecins se débrouillait
bien souvent ils amenaient leurs aux
aiguilles parce que les aiguilles qui
étaient livrées par la dgs à la
direction générale de la santé n'étaient
pas les bonnes
d'ailleurs dans son communiqué la
direction générale de la santé dans le
communiqué qu'elle à sortir la pm je
crois hier soir nous dit que elle
rassure tout le monde
elle va donner le protocole il fallait
les antilles on n'avait pas attendu mais
qu'elle va aussi
le bon matériel les coups de la tête
batterie plus tôt elle va livrer le bon
matériel donc là on est relativement
inquiet parce que soit il est là ce
matériel vient ce moment là elle pouvait
le livret soit elle ne l'a pas et on
retombe dans la problématique des
masques au mois de mars
on va acheter des sreg le sertit à un
moment où la demande mondiale en bas se
heurter à une concurrence internationale
et on risque de ne pas attribuer
outre les problèmes liés à l'absence de
matériel adéquat pfizer de son côté se
base sur la décision de l'agencé
européenne du médicament
jusqu'à présent le laboratoire livrer
les pays acheteurs à raison de cinq
doses par flacon ce nombre de doses
ayant été relevé à 6 le laboratoire a
donc saisi la perche pour adapter ses
livraisons de vaccins ce qui n'était
alors qu'une dose bonus devient une dose
en tant que tel nous allons tenir nos
engagements de livraison auprès des
états conformément aux commandes qui ont
été passées celles ci ont toujours été
basé sur un nombre total de doses et non
de flacons et conformément à
l'étiquetage approuvé dans chaque pays
une pirouette qui permet à pfizer de
base et ses livraisons sur l'équation un
flacon et galsi doses la france devrait
donc ainsi recevoir 20 % de flacons en
moins que ce qui était prévu pour le
même prix le laboratoire lui a relevé
ses objectifs de production pour 2021
grâce notamment à se re calibrage et à
la montée en puissance de ses sites de
production d'un des trois milliards de
doses faiza estime être en mesure d'en
produire 2 milliards avec à la clé un
bénéfice non négligeable pour le groupe
américain